le problème c'est qu'on fait face à un
feu qui est principalement un sous bois
ont fait face à de toute petite reprise
par ci par là qui se déplace avec le
vent et c'est compliqué pour nous
d'intervenir
[Musique]
là typiquement on retrouve des
particules encore brûlante
morceaux de souche les morceaux de
troncs d'arbres
qui encore très sec continue de se
consumer après les après les grandes
flammes après les murs de flammes voilà
ce qu'ils attendent pour ces prochains
jours mes collègues et mes collègues sur
le terrain le noyage massif de chacune
de ces parcelles de manière à éviter
toute reprise du feu dans le brûlé qui
poussé par un vent
parfois virulents peut occasionner ce
qu'on appelle des sautes de feu et la
partie brûlé avec son élément à condé
s'en va être projeté dans la partie non
brûlé et on aura un nouveau départ de
feu dont on sait ce que l'on cherche à
éviter
le feu peut repartir
[Musique]
non